all right hello
welcome back hi so you look great you
look much healthier than last time i saw
you right
thank you yeah i've been doing a lot
better so you're no longer living
on the street no sir i'm not i'm not on
skid row anymore
you're in an apartment i am that's great
yeah
yeah i'm in the area but i'm not in
downtown yeah but having a roof over
your head is a really nice thing that's
the fact
that's a fact yeah my health has been
doing better i got real sick for a while
but just symptomatics in my stomach all
that stuff but
um i've been cleaned up pretty much off
of everything
um in weed except for um in cigarettes
but yeah i haven't really been and i
haven't been around it
so your last talk was very heavy very
much so
yeah very very it was traumatic just
watching you go through it
yeah it's hard to think about and i
can't watch the and how did that
how did that talk affect you oh
i i still have
um i guess flashbacks would be the
clearest memories i guess
that kind of deal of what you were
talking about right
right and i just yeah um that's hard to
talk about
yeah and then for whatever reasons like
really loud noises for even
cars or just something booming just
instills a terror in me
so i'm not sure why but i still wake up
every day and
like i said grab the world by the
cojones and say let's go
why not so a while back i helped you out
a little bit to
to get a motor home but you you've yet
to do that right not yet yeah it's still
in the works
that's still in the works yeah right
yeah and so so where where does your
life go from here
where do you think you're getting well
it's it's wide open actually um like i
said
the rv is the goal to have a i guess
a home that you can travel in but one
that it's yours
and then um i might go back to school
just for some like psychological or even
art classes
just to you know maybe i don't know um
but i'm thinking also of going up to
like either the woodsy area or maybe
going up to like world tour like
washington maybe i'm not sure yet
the world's your the whole country is
your oyster
kind of yeah where you want yeah kind of
so
but things have been going really well
and um in fact the gal that i had met
through a mutual friend of ours um was a
lady that um
offered with her roommate offered to let
me move in with them
so i was grateful for that and she her
and i get along real well and in the
other room maybe we all get along really
well
nice to have some friends right yes yeah
i've been fortunate
so but um yeah and you you're a skid row
for how long
almost a year almost a year what do you
make of what do you make of skid row
oh um how was your year living here in a
tent
it was interesting to say the least
terrifying to say the least
an experience like none other i don't
believe anyone could ever get unless
they were out here to experience it
and to this day just about everything i
still see and experience
is something i've only ever seen on tv
so my job will still hit the ground
but um i tried it out here
but i i'm i'm convinced that when you
don't have a good health
to be strong out here it really makes a
difference i think the stress of being
down
here maybe wears you down definitely the
filth of skid row maybe boosts your
immune system but the stress of it
right breaks everything else down right
yeah so
yeah but yeah so
i'm kind of excited to see what happens
next and i'm i'm
always peeling and looking through the
um
things on the internet for rvs and
different places so
keeping everything positive and just
waiting to see what happens next well
it's nice to see somebody
turning the corner and actually making
improvement i'm so grateful you're one
of the few
i and i'm very grateful so grateful and
so appreciative
appreciative for the people that opened
up their home to me
you know and got me off the street and
have been helping me and
been a support and have turned into
somewhat of a family
so it's kind of cool it's great yeah
and uh all the traumatic stuff you went
through
earlier in your life does that still
haunt you and slow you down or um
i've been having a lot more recurring
night terrors in the last few months
but there's been a lot going on also
with the holidays and then family
members blah blah
um but i am establishing a doctor
and i'm going to be going to um a
psychiatrist i believe it is yeah to try
to talk about some things because
it could help so what i'm doing is a
little bit more difficult so i think i'm
gonna see check it out can't hurt
so and if it doesn't work well okay
think anyway
so but yeah excellent
well i wish you the best of luck with
that well thank you
thank you keep improving i hope i hope
too
yeah i hope to next goal is the rv get a
hold of the family and just start and
be happy good for you thank you
the drug use what's happened with your
drug use the drug use is all but
no all but no there are occasions when i
will
acquire my my drugs of choice but
they're very small amounts and they're
less than than twice a month
sometimes not even once a month but i
have my weed because it helps
everything and i am trying to quit
smoking cigarettes
but the whole nervous thing with the
anxiety still gets in the way
but i have a doctor that i'm trying to
establish in hollywood
and i have an appointment on the 9th and
they want to do blood work and
try to start everything so it's taken a
while
but i'm i'm starting to get things put
in back in order
so yeah and as soon as i can get my
probably a little pause on an rv that's
a done deal
just a done deal doesn't even have to be
a big one new one nothing now i'll
doctor it up but you know
that's great excellent okay that's all
we need
all right that was such a nice change
from the last time oh my gosh right